اخباركم شكرا لزميله احمد الهادي ساعه
اخباريه جديده نخصص معظمها لتغطيه المشهد
في السودان اهلا بكم
استمرار الاشتباكات المتقطعه في محيط
القياده العامه في الخرطوم مع تسجيل
تحليقا لمقاتلات فوق العاصمه
الجيش والقوات الدعم السريع يتبادلان
الاتهامات بخرق الهدنه المعلنه
دقائق قليله وتصل هذه السفينه وهي سفينه
اماله جدله دخلت الى
استمرار عمليات الاجلاء من السودان
والسفينه السعوديه امانه تنفذ اكبر عمليه
اجراء من بورت سودان منذ بدايه الصراع
ومن اخبارنا الاخرى لافرب يقول ان محاولات
الغرب لعزل موسكو فاشلات ويشدد على ضروره
وجود عالم متعدد الاقطار
حياكم الله في اخر التطورات المتعلقه في
السودان تتواصل مع الاشتباكات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع في عده نقاط سيما
العاصمه الخرطوم رغم موافقه الطرفين على
هدنه خامسه لوقف اطلاق النار كما تشهد
سماء الخرطوم تحليقا كثيفا لطائرات حربيه
في وقت ان تسمع اصوات دويه المدفعيه
ومضادات الطائرات اما في مدينه ام درمان
ادى سقوط قذيفه على احد المنازل الى مقتل
شخص
قال الجيش السوداني في بيان الرسميه انما
حصل كان محاوله فاشله للاستيلاء على الحكم
بقوه بقوه المتمردين واكد بان محاولات
المتمردين واعوانهم من عملاء دخلوا الخارج
في التسوق في التسويق لمشروعهم القائم على
تزييف الحقائق قد فشلت واشار البيان الى
ان المعركه وحدت الشعب وقواته المسلحه
وزادت من حرص ابناء الوطن على اهميه بقايا
قواته المسلحه كما اكد البيان على العمل
على تهيئه الظروف المناسبه في كل اجهزه
الدوله من استئناف عملها وعوده الحياه
لطبيعتها باسرع وقت ممكن
بدورها اتهمت قوات الدعم السريعه الجيش
السوداني بخرق الهدنه الانسانيه المتفق
عليها عبر مهاجمه مراكزها وعدد من الاحياء
السكنيه في الخرطوم بواسطه الطيران
والمدفعيه هذا هو جددت قوات الدعم السريع
في بيان لها التزامها الكامل بالهدنه
الانسانيه المعلنه لفتح ممرات امنه
للمواطنين لقضاء احتياجاتهم ولتسهيل
عمليات الاجلاء
معنا من قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في جده
سلطان السلمي سلطان اهلا بك ما الجديد
لديك
اهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه العربيه بالفعل
بدات عمليات الانزال كما نشاهد اكثر او
قرابه الشخص وتحديد 1982 شخص من مختلف
الرعايه والجنسيات يصلون الان او يتم تبدا
بدات عمليات الانزال من علامات سفينه امان
السفينه التجاريه السعوديه التي قامت
باجلاء هؤلاء الرعايه من ميناء بورتسودان
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في رحله
بحريه استغرقت قرابه الاثنى عشره ساعه
وايضا من من ضمن هؤلاء الرعايه منهم على
متن سفينه اماله جده 65 مواطن ايراني تم
اجلاهم من قبل السلطات السعوديه من ميناء
بورد سودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
خانه قد التقينا بعدد من المسؤولين
الايرانيين والرعايه الذين عبروا عن
امتنانهم وشكرهم وسلاسه وسهوله التنسيق من
قبل السلطات السعوديه لبدء عمليات اجلائهم
من بورت السودان في او من مناطق الفوضى
والاشتباكات المسلحه هنا في الخرطوم
والولايات التابعه لها برا في مسارات امنه
الى الى مدينه بورتسودان ومن ثم الى مينا
بورتسودان وبدات عمليات اجلائهم او
اجلائهم من علامه هذه السفينه التجاريه
الضخمه التي على متنها
1982 الشخص سنتحدث على عدد كبير من
الجنسيات الاوروبيه والاجنبيه وكذلك
الجنسيات العربيه الان بدات عمليه الانزال
كما نشاهد الان في هذه اللقطات على الشاشه
بشكل مباشر نشاهد الانزال بدات العمليات
بطريقه او بالنظام التالي بدءا من كبار
السن وذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه والنساء وبعد
ذلك يقوم تقوم طاقم السفينه بانزال بقيه
الرقاب الركاب من قام باستقبالهم عدد من
القيادات الامنيه التابعه بالقوات البحريه
وعدد من المجلدات السعوديات وكذلك
المديريه العامه للجوازات وعدد من قطاعات
العسكريه والحكوميه الاخرى لتسهيل اجراءات
عمليه الانزال وانهاء اجراءات دخولهم الى
اراضي السعوديه بعد ان يتم منحهم تاشيرات
استثنائيه نظرا لهذا الموقف الانساني
نتحدث انه قرابه خمسه الاف شخص وصلوا خلال
منذ الايام الماضيه وحتى هذه اللحظه الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بعد ان تم
اجلائهم بحرا عبر اثنا عشر سفينه منها
عشره سفن عسكريه سعوديه واثنتين مدنيه وهي
سفينه امانه جده التي تستوعب اعداد كبيره
جدا من الركاب مشاعر امتنان وفرح كبيره
على وجوه هؤلاء الرعايه بعد ان وصلوا الى
بر الامان بعد ان كان هنالك او عاشوا
معاناه كبيره بكل تفاصيلها هنالك في
السودان في مناطق الاشتباك المسلح بين
قوات الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني ايضا
عروف ظروف قاسيه عاشوا تفاصيلها من خلال
شح المياه وانقطاعات الكهرباء وقله
التمويل الغذائي منذ بدات عمليات الاجلاء
على السفلى العسكريه السعوديه وحتى
المدنيه السعوديه يتم استقبالهم وتسكنه في
غرف خاصه بهم وتقديم الرعايه الصحيه
والطبيه ان احتاجوا لذلك طوال مده الرحله
وايضا يتم انهاء اجراءاتهم فور وصولهم
كذلك فيما يتعلق بخدمات الاعاشه يتم
تقديمها طوال الرحله وايضا يتم التعامل مع
هؤلاء الرعايه بشكل انساني كبير جدا نظرا
لظروفهم الصحيه ايضا من علامتنا هذه
السفينه قرابه المئه وخمسه وخمسين شخص من
رعايه منظمه الامم المتحده الامريكيه تم
اجلاؤهم بعد ان تم اجلاء 400 موظف
بالمنظمه خلال الايام الماضيه وتحديد
اليوم الربوع الماضي هذه هي الدفعه
الثانيه وعددها 155 شخص
1982 شخص من الرعايه الاجانب تم اجلائهم
عبر هذه السفينه الضخمه كما نشاهد يتم
استقبالهم بالورود وبالحلوى وبالترحيب
الحار من قبل القطاعات الامنيه السعوديه
المشاركه فيها في عمليات الاجلاء الان سوف
يتوجهون بعد قليل الى حافله الحافلات
الخاصه
هؤلاء الرائده تم تجهيز اسطول كامل من
الحافلات لنقل من المقرات السكن حتى
يستطيعون الاستراحه واخذ قسطا من الراحه
وسوف يتم انهاء اجراءات سفر الى بلدانه في
ظرف ثمانيه واربعين الساعه بعد ان يتم
التاكد من تلبيه كافه احتياجاتهم الخاصه
والصحيه اثناء وجودهم بمدينه جده طيب نحن
نتحدث
حينما نتحدث ايضا كانت هناك اخبار عاجله
ان السفينه السعوديه امانه تنفذ اكبر
عمليه اجلاء من السودان منذ بدء
الاشتباكات وكذلك ان الخارجيه السعوديه
قالت انها اجلت اكثر من
4,738
شخصا منذ بدء العمليات نحن نتحدث عن اكثر
من 139
سعوديا وكما اشار الزميل السلطان قبل قليل
نحو 65 مواطنا ايراني من الرعايه
الايرانيين ايضا سعادتهم المملكه العربيه
السعوديه على الخروج وتم اجلائهم من
السودان السلطان
متى من المتوقع ان تنتهي هذه العمليه
عمليه انزال
الرعايه الذين تم اجلائهم من من بورتسودان
او من السودان تحديدا وهل تمت ايضا على
الجدول بعض السفن القادمه والتي تحمل على
متنها ايضا من تم اجلائهم من هناك
بالفعل عمليات النزول من علامات هذه
السفينه تتم وفق بروتوكول يتبعوا هؤلاء
العاملين على طاقم السفينه وكذلك القيادات
المتواجده على ارض قاعه الملك فيصل
البحريه بجده بدا بانزال الجرحى او حتى
المصابين او اصحاب او اصحاب ذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه ومن ثم بقيه الركاب قبل
بدء في هذه التفاصيل نشاهد الان نزول
رعايه منظمه الامم المتحده كما اشرنا قبل
قليل عددهم 155 شخص كانوا جميعا موظفي
بالفعل موظفي الامم المتحده في السودان
بداوا باداه عمليات انزالهم وهم المتعددين
الجنسيات ومختلف الجنسيات الان بدات
عمليات الانزال الخاصه بهم سوف يكون في
استقبالهم عدد من مسؤولين منظمه الامم
المتحده هنا في قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بعد ذلك سوف يتم انزال بقيه الركاب سوف
يكون في استقبالهم سفراء وقناصل
منذ الساعه ونصف من الان سوف تستغرق عمليه
الانزال من الساعتين الى الثلاث ساعات
نظرا للعدد الكبير لهؤلاء الركاب الذي يصل
الى الف وتسعمائه واثنين الشخص نتحدث على
انه تم التعامل مع بعض الحالات الصحيه من
قبل الهلال الاحمر السعودي مهتم مباشره
الحاله فور نزولهم تم اجلاهم عبر مركبات
الاسعاف قد يكون هنالك اشخاص مصابين
باصابات خفيفه او جروح بسيطه من خفيفه
لمتوسطه او حتى اصحاب امراض مزمنه يتم
التعامل معهم واستقبالهم والتعامل بشكل
صحي فورا عبر مستشفيات مدينه جده ايضا
نتحدث انه فيما يتعلق بعمليات انهاء
الاجراءات والتسكين سوف تتم في ساعتين فقط
من بدءا من انزالهم من انزالهم من علامات
هذه السفينه وصولا الى الحافلات ومن ثم
بعد ذلك الى مقرات السكنه خصصتها الحكومه
السعوديه حتى يستطيع هؤلاء الرعايه
الاستراحه وانهاء كافه الاجراءات الخاصه
بهم الان سوف نحاول ان ننتقل الى الجانب
الاخر وتحديدا
بالقرب من البوابه الخاصه
لسفينه امانه السفينه التجاريه السعوديه
التي نفذت اكبر عمليه اجلاء منذ بدء
الازمه في السودان من ميناء بورتسودان الى
مدينه جده وتحديدا لقاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه كما نشاهد الان القيادات الامنيه
بالقوات البحريه السعوديه متواجده ايضا
قطاعات امنيه اخرى حتى يتم تسهيل وتدليل
كافه الصعوبات الخاصه بانهاء اجراءات صفا
او دخول لهؤلاء الرعايه في ظرف مده تتجاوز
الساعه واحده كذلك وجود ممثلين من وزاره
الخارجيه السعوديه للتاكد من اجراء عمليه
الانزال وفق ما هو متبع اليه ايضا المتوقع
خلال الساعات القادمه ان تاتي كذلك ان تصل
سفينه تابعه للقوات البحريه السعوديه الى
قاعه الملك فيصل البحريه بجده وعلى متنها
عدد من الرعايه و جنسيتهم ايضا نؤكد انه
12 رحله تمت منذ بدا عمليه الاجلاء من
ميناء بورت سودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه
ذهابا وايابا وهي سفن وهي عددها عشره سفن
بحريه واثنتين فقط من السفن المدنيه وهي
سفينه امانه تحديدا التي تستطيع استيعاب
اعداد كبيره نظرا لكثره الطلبات التي تصل
الى الحكومه السعوديه لاجلاء رعاياها من
قبل حكومات الاجنبيه طيب حينما نتحدث عن
هذه السفينه متى انطلقت من السعوديه الى
بورتسودان حتى تجلب على متنها كلها هؤلاء
الذين تم اجلائهم
سلطان
رحله اتجهت مساء امس في رحله استغرقت
اثناء فقط لنذكر ذلك
الرعايه في ظرف نعم وفي ظرف ثلاثه ساعات
تم اجلاء الرعايه عبر الزوارق خاصه بقوات
البحريه السعوديه حتى وصلوا على متن هذه
السفينه ايضا ممكن نلتقي باحد الرعايه
هذه السفينه ومعددهم محدود جدا نعم في
انتظارهم الان وصولهم نعم
احنا نتحدث عن 65 استقبالهم من كما اشرت
65 شخص ايراني كانوا من ضمن الذين تم
اجلائهم عدد من موظفي الامم المتحده تفضل
ايضا ممكن نتعرف عليك
صالح بن احمد بن حميد
انا من السودان جاي من المدينه في
السعوديه عايش انعم
نعم
متجوز في السودان ومن عندي عائله والحمد
لله
انت وعائلتك كامله نعم
بخصوص الاجراءات اللي تمت كيف شفتها الحمد
لله في امن وامان الحمد لله بعض الامراض
والحمد لله اللي وصلنا بلدنا في امن وامن
وامان وخير شكرا لك شكرا
نذكر ان الخارجيه السعوديه قالت بانها تمت
او تم اجراء 139 شخصا سعوديا تم اجلائهم
هي تتحدث
والحديث للخارجيه السعوديه عن اكثر من
وسبعمائه وثمانيه شخصا من رعايه 96 دوله
تم اجلاؤهم السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته يعطيك العافيه كيف حالك نتعرف
عليك
نعم زميلنا عادل تفضل تفضل
نتعرف عليك
اشكر الملك سلمان ولي عهده وبصراحه طالما
عندنا سفاره زي المملكه العربيه السعوديه
احنا في امان اشكر جميع اعضاء السفاره
بالذات استاذ رافت الله يعطيه العافيه
ودام عزك يا وطن اليوم في السودان
في الحافلات يترجمون علينا
يسالون من الجنسيات خلاف ذلك
لكن دام عزك يا وطن وصلتك اليوم
كمواطن السعوديه كيف شفت الخدمات اللي
اللي واجهتها وحصلتي عليها اثناء عمليه
الاجلاء والله خدمات ممتازه ما اقدر اقول
فيها اي شيء امانه لدرجه انه السفير
يتفقدنا نائب القنصل كل شوي كان انا اخر
وحده تم اجلائي من ام درمان فالسفير كان
امانه كل شويه يتصل ورينا خط سيرك
ما اقدر اقول غير كده انا جدا فرحانه ودام
عز المملكه
شكرا يعني هذه هي امتنان وتقدير ومشاعر
لهؤلاء الرعايه السعوديه اذا وصلوا نتعرف
عليك بدايه مازن حميشه من سوريا انا اليوم
الواصلين ان شاء الله بالسلامه على جده
اول شيء انا بحب اشكر كل الجهود اللي
تقدمت لالنا ان كان بمدينه بورسودان وفعلا
يعني المجموعه اللي كانت موجوده هناك نحن
تابعنا معاهم والله 24 ساعه متابعين مع
الجميع وعم اهتمام في الجميع واهم شغله
رغم كل الضغط اللي هم فيه الابتسامه اللي
حاضره المساعده على اعلى المستويات
الموجوده في مدينه البور السوداني الي
الشكر يعني بحب ارسلهم هلا هالشكر هاد
والاكيد للمملكه السعوديه لانه بصراحه
الجهود المبذوله هي جهود دول العظمى مش
دوله انتم كجاليه سوريه ايش ابرز المواقف
الصعبه اللي عشتوها في السودان والله نحن
كان في عنا مشكله الاجلاء من مدينه
الخرطوم
السودان هيك مشكله المشكله الثانيه انه
كان عددنا الكبير هذا الموضوع اللي
واجهناه وكان فيه صعوبه فيه بصراحه وهلا
الترتيبات عم تص الموضوع فبارك الله
بالجميع شكرا للجميع شكرا لك الحمد
عدد كبير من اختلاف في الجنسيات كما اعلنت
وزاره الخارجيه في وقت السابق انه تم
اجلاء اكثر من 80 جنسيه
اجنبيه الان سوف ننتقل الى منطقه اخرى او
الى جانب اخر حتى نستطيع اجراء عدد من
المقابلات مع هؤلاء الرعايه باختلاف
جنسياتهم نعم كما نشاهد الان استمرار
عمليات
الانزال بشكل مستمر جدا
وخلال دقائق معدوده سوف ينزل ايضا اخر
الجنسيات اخرى ورعايه من مختلف جنسيتهم
حتى يستطيعوا الوصول الى القاعده وانهاء
كافه اجراءات الدخول الخاصه بهم ممكن ان
نحاول الان الدخول الى الى داخل السفينه
اللي رستوا واخذ لقطات خاصه بكاميرا
العربيه
ونرصد عمليات الانزال من داخل السفينه الى
ارض قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه هنا بمدينه
جده لا تزل عمليات انزال مستمره تتم وفق
بروتوكول متفق عليه في وقت سابق الان تتجه
او ناتش سوف نطلعكم على لقطات حصريه
ومباشره ايضا نشاهد الخدمات الانسانيه
والمساعده الكبيره يقدمها هؤلاء
هذا المشهد يعني مشهد جميل ومشهد كبير على
هواء مباء كما نشاهد
نعم
نعم الصوره تتحدث زميلي عادل
بلدك
بالتاكيد سلطان الوصول الى الوطن والنجاس
والامن تفضل
حتى المستلزمات الشخصيه والحيوانات
الاليفه الخاصه بناء الرعايه يتم اجلؤهم
على متن السفن البحريه السعوديه اليوم
السعوديه تتعامل مع كافه
الرعايه وكافه الالتزامات واحتياجاتهم على
مستوى واحد فقط باختلاف جنسياتهم واديانهم
ايضا نشاهد العسكري السعوديين يقومون
بانزال الحقائب الخاصه بهؤلاء الرعايه
ومساعدتهم بعد رحله ومعاناه كبيره عاشوا
تفاصيلها هنالك في السودان اليوم يصلون
الى ارض القاعه الملك فيصل البحريه بجده
في استقبالهم عدم ممثلين وزاره الخارجيه
وعدد من القيادات والقطاعات الامنيه
المشاركه في هذه في عمليات الانزال
وعمليات الاجلاء بشكل عام
بالتاكيد سنعود اليك
تستطيع
احتياجاتهم والدخول الى السفينه ان كان
ذلك بالامكان او حتى تلتقي بعدد من الذين
تم اجلائهم
بالامان هو اعظم شعور في هذه الرحله
المليئه
بالمخاطر حتى الوصول الى ارض المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في بورس من بورت سودان
طيب سنعود اليك سلطان السلميين من قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه في جده سنعود اليك في
سياق هذه النشره شكرا جزيلا لك حتى الان
افادت نقابه اطباء السودان بارتفاع ضحايا
الاشتباكات في البلاد الى 410 قتيلا من
المدنيين واصابه 2023 اخرين واوضحت
النقابه في بيان لها ان الاقتتال الاخير
في مدينه الجنينه اوقع 89 قتيلا
مشيره الى انه لا يوجد حصر دقيق لعدد
الاصابات واضافت النقابه ان جميع
المستشفيات في المدينه خارج الخدمه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وهذه ايضا صور من جانب من هذه الاشتباكات
التي وقعتها اليوم صور
للمروحيات تحلق في سماء السودان وكذلك
اعمده الدخان كنا قد اشرنا الى ان هذه
الهدنه
التي استمرت مندتيه 72 ساعه بدلا من
الساعه الثانيه عشره ليلا بتوقيت المحليه
للخرطوم وهي الهدنه الخامسه ايضا شهدت
اختراقات
واشتباكات متقطعه في عدد من المناطق
الطيران
[موسيقى]
هل الجيش السوداني اتهم قوات الدعم السريع
بادخال اسلحه وجنود لمستشفى الخرطوم
بتحويل المستشفى وبعض المدارس لتقنات
عسكريه
وجاء في البيان ان المتمردين مستمرون بقصف
الخرطوم وام درمان لجبار السكان على
الاخلاء لافتا الى ان القصف العشوائي
مستمر بمحيط قياده بحري والقياده العامه
ودفاع الجوي واضاف الجيش انه نفذ عمليات
اجلاء عبر مطار مطار وادي سيدنا
وبورتسودا لرعايه بعض الدول
ابدى قائد قوه الدعم السريع في مقابله مع
بي بي سي استعداده لاجراء مفاوضات مع
عقائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان بشرطي وقف
اطلاق النار وقال حميتي لهيئه الاذاعه
البريطانيه انه طلب بالهدنه منذ اليوم
الاول للحرب وان قواته بدات بفتح ممرات
انسانيه داخل مناطق سيطرتها
وفي تصريح للعربيه قال يوسف عزه المستشار
السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان دقلو ان قوته سيطرت على تسعين
بالمئه من ولايه الخرطوم وانها تستطيع
الصمود في المعارك لسنوات يوسف عزت لفت
الى ان المعركه فرضت على الدعم السريع وان
وقف اطلاق النار مرتبط بتنفيذ الجيش لذلك
واكد عزت في لقائه مع العربيه الى ان
البرهان لا يدير المعركه ولا يستطيع وقف
اطلاق النار
قوات الدعم السريع قادره على الصمود قادره
على الصمود واثبتت خلال اسبوعين من الحرب
المتواصله انها ليست ميليشيا انها ليست
قوات انها قوه منظمه تتبع خطط عسكريه
مرتبه لدينا وساطه من من
امريكا من السعوديه لدينا وساطه من
الايجاد لدينا وساطه من دول كثيره صديقه
ومنظمات ندرس كل هذه الخيارات ونحن
استمرار الحرب ولا نريد معاناه شعبنا اي
لكن نريد مبادره تضمن ان يكون هنالك حل
جذري للازمه السودانيه
حتى القوه المدنيه الموقعه على الاتفاق
الايطالي في السودان الطرفين الى الالتزام
التام بوقف اطلاق النار وشددت على ضروره
التقيد بتلك الهدنه التي وافق عليها قائد
الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان بصوره افضل من سابقاتها
كما اشارت الى انها تشد على ايدي قاده
الجيش والدعم السريع التي تعاطت بايجابيه
مع المبادره الامريكيه السعوديه اما فيما
يتعلق بالاوضاع في الجنينه باقليم دارفور
فاعتبرت ان المواجهات القبليه الحاصله
نتيجه مباشره للقتال الذي استعر منذ
الخامس عشر من ابريل الجاري بين القوتين
العسكريتين الكبيرتين في البلاد
هذا ودعتها المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا زخرفه طرفي الصراع في
السودان الاتفاق على وقف دائم لاطلاق
النار وحل الخلافات من خلال المفاوضات
زخرفه اضافت ايضا ان روسيا تبدل كل الجهود
اللازمه لضمان سلامه المواطنين الروس
الموجودين حاليا في السودان مشيره الى ان
بلادها ان بلادها على اتصال دائم مع جميع
الدول ذات الصله بما في ذلك المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
من الرياض ينضم الينا محمود لعوته الكاتب
الصحفي السوداني سيد محمود اهلا بك يعني
قراءتك لما يحدث اليوم عمليات اجلاء كبيره
لرعايه الدول
الهدنه الخامسه لم تصمد ولم تخلوا من
اشتباكات بين الطرفين تفضل
وطبعا يعني المملكه العربيه السعوديه
قامت بدور الجبار ودور انساني كبير جدا في
تنفيذ يمكن اكبر عمليه اجلاء شهدناها في
الفتره الاخيره وتمت بسلام وانا اعتقد هذا
المشهد هو غطى على الحرب كثيرا
يعني اذا
افترضنا ان هذه الاعداد من
الرعايه والموظفين الذين بلغوا اكثر من
5000 من 96 دوله باغون حتى الان في
الخرطوم في ظل يعني الضربات القويه
والمواجهه العنيفه بين الطرفين انا اعتقد
الوضع كان حيكون ماساوي وانه طبعا هذا
الموقف الانساني يجير لي دور المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في هذا الجانب وانا
اعتقد كل الدول اللي اللي رعايه يعني تم
اجلاهم من السودان تواصلوا مع الرسميه في
السعوديه واشادوا بهذا الدور وانا اعتقد
يعني دور اعتقد كبير
ووفقا لامكانيات التي يعني سخرتها
السعوديه في هذا الجانب من قوه بشريه من
تجهيز السفن مختلفه من التعامل الانساني
من الاستعدادات في القطاع الصحي
اللي هو استقبال الحالات الحرجه في اللي
احنا شاهدناها في اذا كان في القاعده
الجويه او في ميناء او في البناء جده
الاسلامي فانا اعتقد انه هذا دور لن ينسى
يعني للسعوديه واعتقد انه لم تشهده
المنطقه من قبل وضع منطقه داخل السوداني
وعمليه الاقتتال رغم يعني هذه الدعوات من
مختلف الاطراف الا ان
الاقتتال مستمر بين الطرفين
وبالرغم من يعني تواصل الدعوات اذا كانت
اقليميه او دوليه او اموميه او من دول
كبرى مثل امريكا وروسيا وفرنسا والسعوديه
ومصر
انا اعتقد الجانب الداخلي اذا ما هو شعر
بمسؤوليته تجاه الشعب السوداني انا اعتقد
هذا القتال لن يتوقف انا اتعقد المفروض
اللذان يقودان الحربان الان او الاشتباكات
العسكريه في السودان عليهم ان يشاهدوا
المناظر
الكارثيه السيئه في الشوارع في المستشفيات
في
هروب كثير من الناس من الخرطوم الى دول
المجاوره الى الاقاليم الولايات يعني الان
في ارقام كبيره جدا يمكن بالذات في اقليم
دارفور يعني الذين نزحوا الى تشاد بحوالي
270 الف لاجي سوداني ونحن نعلم تماما انه
يعني تشاهد نفسه تواجه اقتصاديه صعبه فلا
تستطيع ان تستقبل هذه
الكميات او الاعداد من اللاجئين ولا ننسى
الموقف الانساني انه في ناس سرقوا بيوتهم
وخلوها يعني بسبب هذه الحرب فانا اعتقد
انه لو ما استشعر الجانبان بهذه الموقف
الماساوي انا اعتقد
النداءات لا تاتي اكلها ولكن طبعا هنالك
وسائل ضغط المفروض المجتمع الدولي او
الدول الكبرى او الدول الاقليميه تمارس
ضغوط على الجانبين حتى يرضخوا ان يجلسوا
في طاوله توطفات يعني واحده ويناقشوا
المساله من برمتها
ويناقش ايضا الاسباب التي دعت الى اندلاع
هذا
الاقتتال حتى يصلوا الى صيغه طردي الطرفان
ولكن طبعا يعني نحن بنشاهد من التصريحات
اللي تنقلوها انتم القنوات الاخرى هنالك
تناقض كبير جدا في الجانبين منهم من يريد
الهدنه والتفاوض ونعتقد الجيش السوداني هو
الاكثر متمسك بمثله انه هو يريد ان يحسم
المسكره المساله العسكريا باعتبار انه
قوات الدعم السريع هي قوات انشقت او تمردت
على الجهه السوداني باعتباره هو جيش نظامي
والمفروض يعني هو يردخ قوات الدعم السريع
وقائدها وزعمه يردخون لاي قرارات تاتي من
الجيش السوداني والاحتكام لمساله الانضمام
في فتره زمنيه وجيزه لقوات الشعب المسلحه
فانا اعتقد المشهد حيكون قاتم جدا كما ذكر
الامين العام المتحده في مقابلته انه
الوضع سيء في ظل انه هذه المنطقه يعني
بتفتقد لعدم الامن تواجه مشاكل صراعات
سياسيه مختلفه وتعاني من مشاكل الانسانيه
نقص في الغذاء وفي كل الاشياء التي ضروريه
التي يتطلبها الانسان فانا اعتقد ان اذا
ما كان هنالك يعني تدخل يعني قوي من جهات
معينه تضغط على الطرفان انا اعتقد بامكانه
الضغط على الطرفي
الصراع يعني هذه الولايات المتحده لا ترى
في تغيرا للوضع الامني القريب ايضا يعني
ما كنا نتحدث عنهم من تصريح لزخرفه وايضا
العديد العديد من حتى غوتيرش الامين
العامله للامم المتحده يدعو الطرفا ولكن
ليس هناك احد يستطيع الضغط
انا ممكن اجاوب على هذا السؤال من جانبين
اول حاجه بالنسبه للاونمم المتحده الان
حتى الان دورها سلبي هو يعتمد على
المناشده
والنداءات يعني نحن في السودان الان في
الوقت الحالي لا نحتاج لموقف ادبي لا
نحتاج لموقف ادبي نحتاج لموقف يعني يحاول
من معالجه هذه المشكله يعني الامم المتحده
الان يعني اجلت اكثر من 1200 موظف من
السودان بسبب الحاله الامنيه وهذا طبعا
ظرف ولكن هنالك الان الام المتحده ممكن
تؤدي دور في المناطق الحدوديه عندنا ناس
يعني يعني تكدسون في الحدود التشاديه وفي
الحدود المصريه وفي حدود اسابيع يحتاجون
لاعانات يحتاجون للمياه يعني هذه غير
متوفر هذه ليس في مناطق الصراع ليس مناطق
الافعال المفروض الامم المتحده تؤدي دور
بشكل
الذي يجب ان تقوم به يعني يعني لحد الان
لا توجد اي يعني
اي تحركات او حملات من متحده في هذه
المناطق يعني اديك مثال يعني اما بالنسبه
لامريكا انا بلاحظ انه كل الاشارات بكل
امانه يعني من امريكا بتيجي رسائل يعني
سلبيه او محزنه من امريكا بالتصريحات بانه
الاقتتال لن يقفوا امريكا اذا ارادت ان
تقوم بدور ايجابي تجاه السودان تستطيع ان
تقوم يعني ولكن طبعا محمد يعني اذا اذا
طرف لا يستمعون لاي طلب لوقفه اطلاق النار
بالتالي ماذا على الولايات المتحده او حتى
اي دوله سواء اقليميه ام تستطيع المضي
دائما في دور الوساطه يجب ان يتوقف اطلاق
النار حتى يكون هناك مجال للوساطه كذلك
يا اخي دعنا نتحدث بالمنطق امريكا تعلم
جديدا ان هذول الطرفان سوف يصلان الى هذه
المرحله
انا اعتذر منك باختصار
باختصار يعني امريكا كان عليها قبل ان يصل
هذا الطرفان لهذه النقطه السيئه كان
عليهما ان يعني يطرحان الحلول من قبل ذلك
شكرا جزيلا يا سيد محمود الكاتب الصحفي
السوداني من الرياض شكرا جزيلا لك
منذ بدايه الصراع كان شارع الشغله في حي
الفتحاب بمدينه ام درمان السودانيه شاهدا
على الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع حيث لا تزال حتى اليوم اصوات
الاشتباكات تسمع من سلاح المهندسين القريب
من الحي
المبادرات المفروض يكون بالضغط
يكون في ضغط عديل على الجيش عليه دعم سريع
ناس يستمعوا سياسيين من عساكر
كلهم يتكتبوا عشان ينجحوا
كانت هذه المبادره في سبيلنا بس توظيف
الحرب وربنا يحفظ السودان لانه السودان
كله سودانيين المفروض
الكلام ده
يعتمد الجيش السوداني في معاركه مع قوات
الدعم السريع على عده امور من اجل تحقيق
التفوق في العرض التالي نتعرف على ابرز
مميزات ومكونات سلاح الجو السوداني
والقواعد العسكريه الكبرى في السودان
حرب زادت من ثقل الوضع الاقتصادي على
الاهالي في السودان
ازمه امتدت في كل ولايه السودان واشتدت في
الولايات الشماليه
شحوا المواد الغذائيه بدا واضحا في سوق
القرير في مروي
ة
ارتفاع في الاسعار وشبه عجز في القدره
الشرائيه للمواد الغذائيه ان وجدت
وصل الى 300 حتى 400 في المئه عزه البعض
الى استغلال التجار للازمه
في رمضان كانت بالفلوس
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي زاد الطين بالله
ما اضر بمخزون الغذاء بعد الاحداث
ان شاء الله اقرب الاحداث
ملامحه الاف الان شوال
ومع استمرار المعارك يتوقع تضرر مخزون
الغذائي في عبوم السودان لنحو كارثي
في كل المعارك القتال من الجو يكون فعالا
لبسط السيطره على الارض الجيش السوداني
لجا الى هذا السلاح لمنازله قوات الدعم
السريع اسطول القوات الجويه السودانيه
يعتمد بشكل اساسي على عشر مقاتلات من طراز
29 طائره تمنح الجيش نقطه تفوق بالنظر الى
ميزاتها المختلفه فهي مرنه تطلق صواريخ جو
ارض مقاتله تعتبر ردا تقنيا وعسكريا روسيا
على طائره اف 16 الامريكيه الجيش السوداني
يضم مجموعه اخرى من الطائرات سوفياتيه
الروسيه الصنع منها سبع طائرات من فئتي
ميغ 21 وميك 23 اضافه الى سبعه عشره
مقاتله صخور من فئتي 24 25
ومقاتلات خفيفه من طراز جي 7
من الصين واخرى متعدده المهام من الجيل
الثالث من طراز اف من الولايات المتحده
القوات الجويه السودانيه سبق واعلنت عن
نجاحها في دمج الطائرات المقاتله من
الولايات المتحده والصين وروسيا في شبكه
واحده لتبادل البيانات في العام 2018
حصيله القوات الجويه السودانيه من
الهليكوبترا المقاتله تصل الى 43 طائره من
نوع ميل ميلي اربعه وعشرين صاحبه التصميم
الكلاسيكي اضافه الى ثلاث طائرات هليكوبتر
نقل من الفئه 17 وكذلك 24 طائره من فئه من
ثمانيه في السودان ثماني قواعد جويه
ابرزها قاعده مروي العسكريه الواقعه
بولايه شمال السودان قاعده شهدت مواجهات
ضاريه بين الجيش والدعم السريع في بدايه
الصراع وقاعده وادي سيدنا في ام درمان
فضلا عن قاعده الاوبيض في شمال ولايه
كوردوفان ثم قاعده الخرطوم وسط العاصمه
ومع استمرار المواجهات تستعد الولايات
المتحده لفرض عقوبات جديده على افراد
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع عقوبات تعيد
الى الاذهان تلك التي كانت مفروضه ايام
حكم الرئيس المخلوع عمر البشير بلال
البجدين العربيه
ومع استمرار الاشتباكات هكذا برنامج
الغذاء العالمي في بيان له ان الوضع في
السودان اصبح كارثيا وان اسعار المواد
الغذائيه في السودان ارتفعت بشكل صاروخي
واكد برنامج الغذاء العالمي التزامهم
باستئناف عملياته في السودان داعيا الى
ضروره توقف القتال ولفت برنامج الغذاء الى
انه يجري تقييما للوضع الامني في السودان
لتحديد المواقع الهادئه لتقديم المساعدات
اشتكت طاقم الطبيه العامل في مستشفى في ام
درمان من نقص الموارد بينما يكافح الطاقم
للتعامل مع تدفق المرضى هذا وسجلت نقابه
الاطباء التي تتابع الخسائر في صفوف
المدنيين مقتل 387 مدنيا على الاقل واصابه
1928 اخرين
في نقص كبير في الفوادر الطبيه وفي نفس
كبير في الفاسير بتاعه المستشفى اللي
بتكون في الظروف العاديه متوفره فهسه
حاليا بكون الشفت طويل ما بقدر يسدده
ودكاتره كفايه غالبا بتلقى دورين او دكتور
واحد مغطى مثلا
قسم او جسمان او مرات بتكون الثلاثه اقسام
فالحاجه دي في الظروف العاديه تحصل يعني
بكون في كله قسم بيكون في عدد كفايه من
الدكاتره غالبا ثلاثه او اربعه
بس هسا حاليا الحاجه دي يعني صعبه شديد
يعني الناس بتحاول تمشي المستشفى بقدر
الامكان لانه تقريبا مستشفى النوب هي
المستشفى الوحيده الهلس في الثوره شغاله
يعني
عبر الشباب السميع بان كيف نقدر نوفر
كوادر ونقدر نوفر لهم ترحيل فما نعاني منه
مساله الترحيل وايضا مغص الحاد في كادر
قد تفجر حرب السودان في الشمال صمام
الامانه الاخير لامين الجراح جارتها في
الجنوب التي عانت طوال فتره الانفصال من
حرب اهليه شرسه اذ يبدو ان الازمات عادت
لتوحد مصير الدولتين كانت فتره وحدتهما
اطول من انفصالهم الاسباب في التقرير
التالي
بظروف صعبه وتوقيت بعيد عن الامثل يتحول
الشتات في الحروب الى ازمه قابله للتصدير
سريعا الى دول الجوار صراع الجنرلين دفع
نحو 15 الف نازح من السودانيين وجنوب
السودانيين للعبور الى الضفه الجنوبيه في
اقل من اسبوعين عدد سيصل لمئه وثمانين
الفا في ثلاثه اشهر فقط اذا استمر
الاقتتال وفقا لممثله الامم المتحده في
جنوب السودان الامر شبه المنعدم كان
الدافع الرئيسي لهروب الاله في الى وجهه
ليست اكثر امنا وفقا لما تشير اليه منظمه
الامم المتحده فرحله الفرار الممتده ل500
كيلو متر تقريبا ملغمه بالمخاطر تبدا من
العاصمه بما يتوفر من وسائل مواصلات او
السير مش في احيان والتعرض لخطر هجوم مسلح
الى حين الوصول ولايه النيل الابيض اقرب
نقطه حدوديه جنوبيه للخرطوم هناك حيث يعيش
نحو 300 الف جنوب سوداني في المخيمات جلهم
نزح من حرب اهليه داميه في بلد لا يزال
75% من سكانه يعتمدون على مساعدات انسانيه
تتكفل بثلاثه فقط من احتياجاتهم وضع يزداد
خطوره في ظل هشاشه اتفاق السلام الموقعي
عام 2018 بين فصائل الجنوب والترقب لاول
انتخابات في تاريخ البلاد تجري نهايه
العام المقبل وليس مستبعدا ان تخلق حرب
الشمال فرصه جديده لتنشيط جماعات مسلحه
يلجا اليها القاده المتمردون الغاضبون من
حكومه سيلفاكير رئيس دوله جنوب السودان
حرب ستحرم كذلك عمليه السلام في الجنوب من
الضامن الاقليمي الاكثر نفوذا المتمثل في
ضغوط البرهانه على قاده الجنوب في ملفات
امنيه واقتصاديه ولعل اسوا العواقب
الاقتصاديه تلك التي تهدد خط انابيب النفط
العابر للحدود الى بورتسودان وتحرم وجوبا
من عائدته التي يتقاسمها مع السودان لكن
القضيه الاكثر الحاحا هي تامين خروج اكثر
من 800 الف جنوب سوداني يقطن معظمهم في
الخرطوم واستغلال معاناتهم من تجار
الازمات الذين يعرضون خدمات التوصيل بمبلغ
يصل الى ثمانيه الاف دولار للحافله في ظل
انقطاع الخدمات الامميه هناك كرم حناوي
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات